[Musik]
fliegeralarm in kiel für seit der nacht
greift russland ziel in der ukraine an
aus der luft zur see und am boden
truppen rücken auf die hauptstadt vor
aus dem ganzen land werden tote und
verletzte gemeldet
bundeskanzler scholz spricht von einem
düsteren tag für europa der westen ist
in krisen ausnahmezustand
und damit willkommen an einem tag an dem
alle augen auf den russischen angriff
auf die ukraine und die folgen gerichtet
sind
russlands präsident putin hat also einen
krieg in der ukraine in europa begonnen
wir hören den klang eines neuen eisernen
vorhangs warnt der ukrainische präsident
seelands g er verhängte im ganzen land
das kriegsrecht denn von mehreren seiten
rücken die russischen truppen vor es
gibt berichte dass russische
fallschirmjäger an einem flughafen in
der region kiew abgesetzt werden aus
zahlreichen orten werden gefecht und
explosionen gemeldet ihren kehl und
luton winehouse berichten
zu tode erschrocken erleben diese
ukraine den angriff aus der luft
sowie war himmel schreit einer das
schlägt bei uns ein bei uns
auch einen flughafen im westen des
landes wird am frühen morgen von einem
geschoss getroffen handy videos liefern
die ersten bilder des krieges den befehl
zum angriff hatte russlands präsident
putin nach vier uhr morgens begeben zur
begründung hieß es die separatisten in
den beiden sogenannten volksrepublik im
osten hätten um hilfe gebeten
ziel ist es menschen zu schützen die
acht jahre einem völkermord durch das
regime in kiew ausgesetzt sind wir
werden uns für eine entmilitarisierung
und entnazifizierung der ukraine
einsetzen und diejenigen vor gericht
stellen die zahlreiche blutige
verbrechen gegen zivilisten begangen
haben einschließlich bürger der
russischen föderation
die sogenannte entnazifizierung der
ukraine sollen jetzt rund 180000 kämpfer
ermöglichen angeblich waren sie nur zum
manöver an den grenzen aufmarschiert
jetzt der angriff von drei seiten
gleichzeitig
alarm in kiew die ukrainische regierung
fängt sofort das kriegsrecht präsident
selensky ruft in einer videobotschaft
seine landsleute dazu auf nicht in panik
zu verfallen wir sind stark auf alles
vorbereitet wir werden siegen
raketen schlagen auf dem flughafen
mariupol eines der ersten ziele
russische angriffe russland meldet schon
früh alle angriffe seien erfolgreich
ziele erreicht die ukrainische
luftabwehr und die flughäfen seien
ausgeschaltet überprüfen lässt sich das
nicht viele einwohner der hauptstadt
kiew wollen jetzt nur noch weg raus aus
der stadt die flucht tausender beginnt
aber meist im stau die menschen sind
wütend traurig ernüchtert aber auch
trotzig
wir haben gehofft dass es nicht passiert
es ist unbegreiflich dass ein verrückter
mann so einen befehl
dieser mann watet verzweifelt dass es
endlich weitergeht
es ist einfach nur schrecklich
wo wollen sie hin fragt die reporterin
die kinder abholen sie in sicherheit
bringen sagt er er weint und schimpft
auf putin dieser bastard dieser böse
mann sei verflucht
die berichte über die kampfhandlungen im
land lassen sich nicht nachprüfen klar
scheint die russen erwartet gegenwehr
beide seiten melden kampf erfolge
zerstörte ziele abgeschossene flugzeuge
im russischen staatsfernsehen wird der
angriff akribisch begleitet und
analysiert tenor alles laufe nach plan
dagegen sprechen bilder ukrainische
augenzeugen von getroffenen häuserblocks
und raketen trümmern in wohngebieten die
regierung in kiew macht mobil wir haben
jetzt begonnen waffen zu verteilen sagt
der präsident an jeden der will und in
der lage ist unsere unabhängigkeit zu
verteidigen
in cardiff suchen die menschen schutz in
u-bahn-stationen eine nacht in angst
liegt vor ihnen krieg in der ukraine
tag 1
zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt unser kollege
axel sturm der in der nacht noch in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew
inzwischen hat er die stadt in richtung
südwesten verlassen und ist jetzt in
windows jahr axel was hören sie über die
lage der hauptstadt kiew
ja aus kiew gibt es keine guten
nachrichten der ukrainische präsident
selensky meldet heute am späten
nachmittag
man habe russischen luftlandetruppen im
oblast rundum kiew 20 kilometer entfernt
vom stadtzentrum festgesetzt sie würden
jetzt eliminiert sagte er und der kieler
oberbürgermeister klitschko forderte
auch am späten nachmittag die
bevölkerung dieser riesen stadt dazu auf
schutzräume aufzusuchen dazu soll die
metro dienen die in kiew relativ groß
und ausgebaut ist und es gibt auch
bislang allerdings unbestätigte berichte
über kampfjets die kiew überfliegen
danke für diese einschätzung axel sturm
in der ganzen ukraine und darüber wollen
wir weiter sprechen ist die bevölkerung
in angst und sorge nicht nur in kiew
sondern auch in anderen orten unser
reporter sebastian ist in der stadt
lemberg im westen des landes
sebastian wie gehen die menschen bei
ihnen lembeck mit dieser situation um
also wir haben heute morgen hier sirenen
gehört es wurden drei militärbasen
rundum lemberg beschossen danach wurde
es hier ruhiger in der stadt wir sind
dann mal losgezogen und haben lange
schlangen von nahezu jeder bank gesehen
menschen wollten an bargeld kommen
außerdem waren nämlich bei den
supermärkten extrem viel los brot wurde
gekauft also die leute haben sich
eingedeckt jetzt liegt über der stadt so
eine trügerische ruhe die alles bedeuten
kann wir sehen hier ab und an leute mit
koffern die straße entlang ersten hier
vor unserem balkon von dem wir schalten
hat ein mann gerade sehr schnell sein
auto gepackt auch das
sehen wir dass leute hier die stadt
verlassen also es könnte zu größeren
fluchtbewegungen richtung polnischer
grenze kommen die nur 70 kilometer weit
entfernt ist danke sebastian eben eine
trügerische ruhe die natürlich vom
weiteren russischen einmarsch abhängt
schauen wir jetzt also nach moskau und
gehen zu unserer korrespondentin für
begriffe wie sind die reaktionen in
russland auf den angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine
wir haben dazu heute mal eine kleine
umfrage hier auf moskaus straßen
durchgeführt die ist natürlich nicht
repräsentativ aber es hat sich doch ein
ganz interessantes bild ergeben denn
unter der älteren generation da ist es
so dass uns die überwiegende mehrheit
gesagt hat dass ihr diese
militäroffensive für gut begründet und
logisch hält teilweise glichen die
argumente derjenigen die wir da befragt
haben fast wortgleich denen ihres
präsidenten dessen rede wurde natürlich
heute im staatlich kontrollierten
fernsehen rauf und runter wiederholt
anders sieht es bei der jüngeren
generation aus dass durchaus mehr krieg
skepsis zu hören auch ganz klare
ablehnung es gab hier heute abend in
moskau eine kleinere anti kriegs
demonstration mehrere hundert menschen
sind da zusammengekommen und das obwohl
die polizei im vorfeld den
veranstaltungsort schon abgeriegelt
hatte auch in anderen städten von moskau
gab es kleinere anti kriegs
demonstrationen und etwa 800 festnahmen
sich öffentlich gegen putins weg zu
positionieren das wird hier also nicht
geduldet vielen dank für begann
die g7 forderten russland auf die
truppen abzuziehen
der angriff sei eine ernste bedrohung
der internationalen ordnung so die
sieben führenden wirtschaftsmächte zu
denen auch deutschland gehört
bundeskanzler scholz sagte der ukraine
heute die volle solidarität zu und hielt
eine rede an die nation
gerade erleben wir den beginn eines
krieges wie wir in europa so seit mehr
als 75 jahren nicht erlebt haben
russlands präsident putin hat die
entscheidung getroffen die ukraine
militärisch anzugreifen
das ist ein überfall auf ein
unabhängiges souveränes land das durch
nichts und durch niemanden zu
rechtfertigen das ist der auch grenzen
innerhalb europas gewaltsam zu
verschieben ja vielleicht ein ganzes
land von der weltkarte zu tilgen
voller absicht recht präsident putin mit
den grundprinzipien der charta der
vereinten nationen und mit der
europäischen friedensordnung
er gefährdet das leben unzähliger
bürgerinnen und bürger der ukraine dem
bruder volk russlands weil das geschieht
nicht weit weg von uns sondern hier in
europa
herr die nato will als reaktion auf den
russischen angriff auf die ukraine
weitere soldaten an die ostflanke des
militärbündnisses verlegen in der
ukraine selbst seien aber keine nato
truppen und es gebe auch keine pläne
welche zu entsenden so generalsekretär
stoltenberg für freitag kündigte er
einen virtuellen nato gipfel an am abend
will us-präsident beiden eine rede zum
krieg in der ukraine halten wenn der
mieter berichtet
die ganze welt betet für die menschen in
der ukraine mit diesem satz beginnt das
erste statement des weißen hauses zum
angriff russlands auf seinen nachbarn es
pressiert beiden set wie der
us-präsident klar gestellt hat ist
russland allein verantwortlich für die
toten und die zerstörung die dieser
angriff bringen wird die vereinigten
staaten werden gemeinsam mit ihren
verbündeten und partnern darauf
antworten die welt wird russland für
seine taten zur verantwortung ziehen
die usa verhängen neue sanktionen
betroffen sein sollen russlands banken
seine energiewirtschaft einzelpersonen
und der export von hightech gütern
daneben werden weitere militärische
aktionen beraten noch in der nacht sind
erste us-truppen in riga eingetroffen um
die nato ostflanke zu verstärken
insgesamt sollen mehr als 300
amerikanische soldaten nach lettland
verlegt werden das an russlands
verbündete belarus grenzt die nato
aktiviert außerdem ihre
verteidigungspläne und kann somit
zusätzliche einheiten anfordern im
notfall so generalsekretär stoltenberg
könnte nun auch die nato eingreiftruppe
mit bis zu 40.000 soldaten aktiviert
werden
die nato alliierten verurteilen russland
ukraine invasion scharf und in jeder
hinsicht es ist eine eklatante
verletzung des völkerrechts ein akt der
aggression gegen ein souveränes
unabhängiges und friedliches land und es
stellt eine ernste bedrohung der
transatlantischen sicherheit da eines
zieles jdx
nun hätten wir einen krieg in europa so
stoltenberg von dem man dachte er gehöre
der vergangenheit an nach wie vor bleibt
es aber dabei dass der westen keine
soldaten in die ukraine selbst schicken
wird
heute abend noch will der us-präsident
also vor die presse treten elmar
theveßen wer schon ein bisschen was
gehört aber welche neuen sanktionen wird
gegen russland wird beiden wohl heute
noch ankündigen
also wir gehen davon aus dass er die
fünf größten banken russlands ins visier
nehmen wird das sind die banken die auf
internationalen zahlungsverkehr
angewiesen sind in russland eine große
rolle spielen die größte begrüßte
beispielsweise sberbank ist für 50
prozent der gehälter und renten in
russland für die auszahlung dieser
gelder verantwortlich der zweite punkt
sanktionen gegen personen da könnte es
durchaus sein dass nicht nur das umfeld
von wladimir putin getroffen wird
sondern auch er selber das heißt
guthaben wenn er sie im ausland hat
würden eingefroren niemand dürfte mit
ihm geschäfte machen das dritte ist eben
waffenexport kontrollen entschuldigung
auf hochtechnologie das heißt alle
geräte alle technologie die in
irgendeiner form amerikanisches euro
beinhaltet software hardware mikrochips
beispielsweise würde nicht mehr
geliefert das würde die rüstungs und die
luftfahrtindustrie in russland hart
treffen und das viertel ist vielleicht
das wichtigste dass instruktionen gegen
die energiefirmen russland ist von den
einnahmen durch gas und öl abhängig
natürlich braucht der westen braucht
europa das gas und das öl auch aber in
den vergangenen wochen hat man sicher
gestellt dass man ersatz hat zumindest
mal für die nächsten monate um solche
sanktionen dann auch in westeuropa
auszuhalten das alles das sagt man hier
ganz klar wird wladimir putin nicht
daran hindern die ukraine mit höherer
wahrscheinlichkeit komplett zu
übernehmen eine eigene regierung zu
installieren
aber man will ihm das heizen der ukraine
dann so schwer wie möglich machen danke
für diese einschätzung
durch die bisherigen strafmaßnahmen hat
sich putin auch nicht von dem angriff
abbringen lassen die eu staats und
regierungschefinnen und chefs wollen
sich daher auch auf neue sanktionen
verständigen sie kommen jetzt gerade in
brüssel zusammen die neuen sanktionen
würden der russischen wirtschaft sehr
ernsthaft schaden so
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
mit den einzelheiten florian
schon dass sie als trio vor die presse
treten ist ein seltenes signal heute
scheint es nötig nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg wie kommissionspräsidentin
von der leyen und eu-ratspräsident
michelle haben eine botschaft was
russlands einmarsch bedeutet
kein angriff auf frieden und sicherheit
in ganz europa die eu und ihre
mitgliedstaaten werden gemeinsam mit
ihren verbündeten russland dafür zur
rechenschaft ziehen nach den ersten
sanktionen gegen russische politiker
plant die eu nun härtere maßnahmen
wirtschaftssanktionen die russland
treffen sollen und für die man bereit
ist auch selbst einbußen hinzunehmen am
abend dazu ein sondergipfel in brüssel
ich sonst auch die sanktionen werden der
aggression russlands gegenüber
angemessen sein und wir werden weder
militärisch noch wirtschaftlich und noch
im bereich der energie irgendeine
schwäche zeigen im gespräch etwa
exportverbote bei high tech produkten
einschränkungen bei der vergabe von visa
für russinnen und russen oder das
einfrieren von russischen familie in der
eu
ich pack das paket wird finanzielle
sanktionen beinhalten die russlands
zugang zum kapitalmarkt drastisch
beschränken das wird russland hart
treffen
dem ukrainischen außenminister reicht
das nicht per twitter fordert die
metropole beschließt russland von swift
aus trifft jede hauptsitz vor den toren
brüssels das ist das zahlungssystem über
das tausende banken weltweit ihre
überweisungen abwickeln ein ausschluss
russlands gilt als die härteste waffe
des westens bisher steht er nicht auf
dem plan der eu die gipfel debatte
darüber dürfte noch zu werden
in einer dreiviertelstunde soll die
debatte beginnt beim eu-gipfel es soll
also neue sanktionen geben und dazu
begrüße ich vor ort in brüssel anne
gellinek und in berlin theo koll guten
abend an sie beide beginnen wir mit
ihnen an der ausschluss russlands aus
dem internationalen zahlungssystem swift
wäre also das schärfste schwert warum
ist man sich da nicht einig ja weil der
ausstoß ausschluss aus hilft eben für
beide seiten schwere folgen hätte sowohl
für russland als auch für die
internationale gemeinschaft 12 verbindet
weltweit ungefähr 11.000 banken davon
ausgeschlossen zu werden würde für
russland bedeuten dass es keine
internationalen transaktionen mehr
durchführen kann und das auch im und
exporte nicht mehr abgewickelt werden
können es heißt aber auch für
europäische geschäftspartner dass sie
auch keine importe zum beispiel von gas
aus russland mehr bezahlen könnten und
deshalb wenden sich partner die sehr
viele geschäfte mit deutschland machen
darunter deutschland und die niederlande
gegen diesen ausschluss sie bremsen
dabei im kommissionsvorschlag den die
staats und regierungschefs gleich auf
dem gipfel diskutieren werden ist der
ausschluss vom 12 zahlungssystem nicht
drin es kann aber gut sein dass in der
diskussion heute abend die osteuropäer
die polen und die balten nochmal einen
vorstoß machen und versuchen dieses
scharfe schwert doch noch auf die
sanktionsliste zu setzen gucken wir nach
berlin theo koll was bedeutet denn
dieser krieg für die deutsche politik
gegenüber russland
also mein eindruck ist es der krieg die
deutsche außenpolitik mindestens
gegenüber russland deutlich verändern
wird mit dem heutigen tag hat in berlin
eine art neubewertung begonnen die
bisherige ja eher abrüsten und auf
diplomatie setzen der politik ist für
viele ein offensichtlich hier nicht mehr
ausreichend um sich gegen einen
aggressor wie putin zu behaupten die
außenministerin hat das heute so
formuliert wir sind in einer anderen
welt aufgewacht und das gilt glaube ich
auch politisch vizekanzler habeck sprach
von naivität im umgang mit putin und der
erleben gerade dass auch erfahrene
außenpolitiker wie beispielsweise
norbert röttgen die immer gegen
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine waren
jetzt dafür sind nach der pandemie
scheint dieser krieg nun das zweite
brennglas zu sein dass der deutschen
politik langjährige defizite über
deutlich vor augen führt also durchaus
das potenzial auch für eine zeitenwende
danke nach berlin und bronze für diese
einordnung
und wir bleiben beim blick auf
deutschland das politische ansätze über
den angriff hier ist groß am sonntag
wird kannst stolz eine
regierungserklärung angesichts der lage
der ukraine halten in einer
sondersitzung des bundestages wie soll
deutschland auf putins angriff reagieren
und welche folgen hat der krieg auch für
deutschland peter spiekermann berichtet
sicherheitskabinett im kanzleramt von
kanzler scholz einberufen ministerin
minister der ressorts verteidigung innen
und außen gemeinsam am tisch putin
breche so annalena baerbock mit den
elementarsten regeln der europäischen
ordnung die menschen in der ukraine
hätten ein recht auf demokratie und
frieden
präsident putin diesen traum werden sie
niemals zerstören können er wächst in
der ukraine erwächst genauso in ihrem
land sondersitzung des
verteidigungsausschusses
einigkeit darüber die sanktionen müssten
schnell greifen die union versichert sie
stehe geschlossen hinter der
regierungslinie es sei keine zeit für
parteipolitischen streit sollten ja auch
innenpolitisch sehr klar und deutlich
sagen wir werden jede maßnahme
unterstützen auch als union die darauf
ausgerichtet ist dass nato territorium
vor weiteren übergriffen
russlands zu schützen wenn notwendig
auch militärisch wirtschaftsminister
habe träumt einen der westen sei
gegenüber russland zu naiv gewesen
oberste priorität habe jetzt die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland wir
müssen damit rechnen dass sich
kurzfristig an den rohölmärkten oder gar
an den gasmärkten die preise
nach oben bewegen aber schon
mittelfristig haben wir gute chancen
dass wir die preis den preisanstieg
durch den krieg wieder dämpfen können
nord stream zwei liegt auf eis wieder
wird die kritik lauter deutschland habe
sich zu abhängig gemacht von russland es
ist vielleicht jetzt ein weckruf ein
letzter für all diejenigen die es noch
nicht verstanden haben dass wir
wegkommen müssen von fossiler energie
gas öl kohle hin zu erneuerbaren
energien hin zu mehr energie sparen die
botschaft der regierung deutschland
kommt sicher durch den winter aber zu
welchem preis
deutschland setzt mit der eu und den usa
also auf weitere schärfere
strafmaßnahmen gegen russland valerie
haller für uns an der frankfurter börse
wie sehr treffenden finanzsanktionen
russland also im moment geht es ja vor
allem darum eine handvoll russischer
banken vom westlichen finanzsystemen
auszuschließen ja und damit verliert der
russische finanzsektor schon auch den
zugang zum us dollar das klingt schaaf
muss man aber abwarten denn russland hat
sich spätestens seit der krim krise ein
stück weit auch daran gewöhnt ohne
westliche geldgeber auszukommen ja und
auch die abhängigkeit vom dollar hat
russland sukzessive verringert die
schärfste waffe wäre tatsächlich
russland von swift abzuschneiden dass
man aber zurückhaltend die
kollateralschäden für westliche banken
und unternehmen könnten riesig sein die
börsen haben ja mit schockwellen auf den
krieg reagiert wie äußert sich das genau
ja tatsächlich brechen weltweit die
börsen ein viele investoren flüchten den
anlagen wie gold und deutsche
staatsanleihen weil sie in krisenzeiten
als sichere häfen gelten der dax ist
schon seit tagen unter druck fällt heute
noch mal tief verliert 4 prozent haben
gleichzeitig springt der ölpreis
erstmals seit über sieben jahren über
die marke von 100 dollar das malheur
warten dass die energiepreise nach oben
schnellen russland ist nun mal wichtiger
gas und öl lieferant für deutschland und
europa aber auch einer der weltgrößten
anbieter von aluminium und anderen
industriemetallen die in ganz ganz
vielen produkten stecken und das
bedeutet nichts gutes für die schon hohe
inflation in deutschland und europa die
preise dürften also erstmal weiter nach
oben gehen danke walhalla
krieg in europa der russische angriff
auf die ukraine gleich nach und sehen
sie ein zdf spezial bis zum heute
journal
darin ein was nun annalena baerbock
fragen an die außenministerin und eine
gesprächsrunde bei maybrit illner über
die neuesten entwicklungen hält sie
außerdem unsere zdf heute app auf dem
laufenden zb mit einem live blog
und auch der internationale sport
reagiert die uefa die europäische
fußball union wird sankt petersburg wohl
das champions league finale einziehen
offiziell soll das morgen entschieden
werden der russische staatskonzern
gazprom gehört zu den größten sponsoren
der uefa und auch bei schalke 04 für die
nächsten spiele verschwindet der
schriftzug von den trikots
auch das rosen montags fest des kölner
karnevals ist abgesagt stattdessen soll
es eine friedensdemonstration in der
innenstadt geben wegen der korona
pandemie war sowieso alles eine nummer
kleiner geplant mit einem fest im
fußballstadion
viele menschen in deutschland sind
erschüttert und entsetzt über das was
passiert in der ukraine und spüren wut
und ohnmacht hier einige stimmen aus
berlin ich finde das ganz schrecklich
und deswegen und werde hier weil wir
eben angst vor diesem krieg haben und
der ja auch jetzt ganz offiziell
begonnen hat auch mit bodentruppen
soweit ich meine das jetzt hört das ist
natürlich eine situation die wir zum
glück ganz lange in europa nicht hatten
total geschockt aber nicht überrascht
also das war schon irgendwie
hätte ja sonst kann es in haft diese
ganzen truppenaufmarsch dort zu haben
dann irgendwie wieder weg zu gehen das
ist eine katastrophe ich weiß nicht ich
weiß nicht was
dazu sagen kann
wir beide kommen aus russland
und hier sind ich weiß nichts das ist
ein wahnsinnig glaub ich spreche für
alle wenn wir sagen dass wir angst haben
und besorgt sind und dann zeit fragen
wie es weitergeht
so wie sie die bilder aus berlin und aus
solidarität mit der ukraine haben sich
am brandenburger tor in berlin mehrere
tausend menschen versammelt für uns vor
ort ist nils schneider jetzt wie erleben
sie den protest
die stimmung hier ist sehr gedrückt die
menschen hinter mir am brandenburger tor
sie sind wütend sie sind traurig und sie
machen sich sorgen große sorgen um ihre
familien und freunde in der ukraine den
viele der demonstranten hinter mir haben
ukrainische wurzeln aber wir haben ja
auch menschen getroffen die aus russland
stammen aus weißrussland andere
berlinerinnen und berliner sind hier in
solidarität mit der ukraine gegen krieg
und für frieden auf den transparenten
und plakaten die sie dabei haben liest
man immer wieder stoppt putin stoppt den
krieg das ertönt auch immer wieder in
sprechchören die aus der menge heraus
kommen seit dem mittag wird hier am
brandenburger tor demonstriert im laufe
des tages des frühen abends hat sich die
zahl der menschen immer mehr erhöht und
sie stehen jetzt bis zur russischen
botschaft die zirka 100 meter von ihr
entfernt ist das ist zwar für berlin für
die hauptstadt noch immer keine riesige
demonstration aber es ist ein erstes
wichtiges zeichen gegen krieg und für
den frieden danke nach berlin nicht
schneider
ein tag bestimmt von der nachricht des
russischen angriffs auf die ukraine die
wetteraussichten haben wir auch heute
für sie sie werden sie gleich erfahren
von bis denn terry den ganzen abend über
informieren wir sie in mehreren spezial
sendungen über die neuesten
entwicklungen und hintergründe um 21.45
das heute journal mit christian sievers
in allen einen guten abend
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter mit dem durchzug der kaltfront
wird es ungemütlich es gibt schauer und
gewitter und morgen im tagesverlauf
kommt kältere luft heran und so gibt es
weitere gewitter teilweise auch mal
schnee bis ins flachland
in der nacht gibt es regen und schnee
das verlagert sich nach osten und
südosten es wird teilweise glatt auf den
straßen
ja und das bei temperaturen von null bis
minus 3 grad morgen teils live also
weitere schauer und gewitter die auch
ziehen und sich allmählich nach südosten
verlagern zwischendurch auch mal längere
zeit sonnenschein aber auch viel wind
dabei durchaus in der nähe von gewittern
auch mal stürmische böen oder sturmböen
das war temperaturen von drei grad an
den alpen 10 grad im südwesten häufig
werte unter der zehn grad marke ja am
samstag lassen die schauer allmählich
nach die sonne kommt immer häufiger
hervor bei zwei bis neun grad und ab
sonntag gibt es viel sonnenschein ein
schöner amt